[Music]
marisa is with us in phoenix hi marisa
what's up
hi i'm grateful to be here thank you for
taking my call sure how can we help
i am engaged and um something that i'd
like before the wedding is
for my fiance to get out of credit card
debt good what's he made just recent
it
makes about a hundred thousand a year
how much is his credit card debt
thirty five thousand has he got any
money
um
a little bit of an emergency savings how
much
a thousand dollars okay got baby step
one
okay
and uh when are you planning on getting
married
no date set because it's important to me
that we can
tackle this um credit card debt no we
don't tackle credit card debt when we
aren't married he tackles credit card
debt
yes you don't pay his debt until you're
married he pays it
got it that's clear yeah that that's
going to create a strain on the
relationship and a major mess in the
event of a breakup
and no you don't want to do any of that
it's not good for anybody involved so
now and i i you can do what you want to
do we at ramsey don't tell people to
avoid marriage because of debt we do
tell people to avoid marriage
because someone doesn't want to deal
with their debt but if your fiance is
plowing into this and is aggressively
attacking it using the debt snowball
living on a budget being careful being
wise being frugal and hitting this debt
hard and he's knocked off ten thousand
of the thirty thousand and you can see
that he's well on his way and he's a
changed man and the credit cards are cut
up then i i wouldn't as my if you were
my daughter i would tell you to marry
him
and that's what i'm working working
towards but um he recently talked to me
about
him taking out a personal loan
or some options in consolidating his
credit card debt which leads me to
calling you because he finally gave me
that green light where he's ready
to move forward so you don't need to
consolidate anything you just need to
pay it it makes a hundred thousand
dollars a year he can pay it really
really fast he hasn't got any expenses
except you right now and you could be
determined to not be an expense starting
ready set go
yeah uh what we need to do is we'll get
you guys into financial peace university
hold on kelly i'll sign you guys up
we'll give it to you as an advanced
wedding gift and you guys go through it
and start talking about it but he pays
his own debt and he starts on it
immediately and we don't borrow our way
out of debt with consolidation